[Musique]
je vous amène aujourd'hui à la boutique
orange opéra pour parler de nouveaux
smartphones que lens orange neva jet
signés orange alors ce qu'on va faire
aujourd'hui l'exercice ici et la
boutique orange opéra on va se nourrir
on va regarder comment effet ce
smartphone ça c'est la première étape on
va faire le nom boxing ensemble et d'ici
quelques jours
et sinon un petit peu de temps je vous
dirais exactement ce que j'en pense tout
ça dans une seule et même vidéo regardez
moi ça ici elle a vu par la fenêtre
moussa le spot est complètement ouf on a
la vue sur l'opéra garnier
là c'est juste difficile en fait c'est
dans une très très très très grande
salle salle de réception pour ya comme
ça vous avez la vue de tous les côtés
donc si vous voulez venir profiter de la
vue qu'à écouter via la boutique anges
bon aujourd'hui le ciel est pas terrible
terrible mais s'il n'en garder pour
profiter du toit de l'opéra garnier
packaging plutôt cool aux couleurs
d'orange
vous le retrouvez ici marqué neva jet
orange on voit le smartphone on va le
voir dans quelques instants vous allez
voir on retrouve vraiment tous les codes
couleurs dans les codes couleurs
d'orange qui fonctionne laure joly
orange qui est là et on voit que le
produit en fait est fabriqué par zte
axle 10 pro 5 g et lorna les petits
pictos qui me donne un peu plus sur
l'adn de ce produit on voit
effectivement marqué 5 gt à dire que le
smartphone et 5g compatibles à noter
comme je le disais qu effectivement mais
pour l'instant la socgen n'est pas
l'épaule en france donc vous pouvez pas
prendre de forfaits et 5g et même si
votre smartphone est prêt pour la 5g
vous ne pouvez pas l'utiliser sur la 5g
joug d'une fois de plus cela fera tant
qu en 2020 et bien le réseau 5g soir en
place soit disponible pour le grand
public et qu'elle et offre donc une fois
que c'est en place va vous avez souscrit
à une offre est bien votre smartphone
sera prêt pour l'instant que j pour ça
c'est plutôt bien donc ça sert et
version un peu je dirais standard vous
pouvez acheter dès maintenant avec le
petit logo 5 février les cinq gérer 10 5
jeux compatibles et y aura une version
directement hop comme sa marque et 5 g
en gros lorsque l'offre sera disponible
lorsque la 5g sera déployé dans c'est
plutôt bien vous voyez donc cette petite
boîte celle là c'est exactement la même
chose lorsque le le message est beaucoup
plus clair on va qu'on a
vers gorilla glass display donc à
l'avancé protéger si j'y viendrai à une
batterie de 4 millions période plutôt
bien 48 mégapixels au niveau de la
caméra 20 mégapixels caméra trafiquants
et un écran amoled de 6,47 pouces qu'on
est un qualcomm snapdragon 855 si giga
de ram 128 go de stockage et une triple
caméra à l'arrière mais ça pour vous le
montrer on va s'ouvrir ensemble déjà
qu'on peut regarder comme ça j'aime bien
vous avez des banques qui remet sur les
côtés ça c'est très joli
on voit qu'on a la petite caméra qui est
ici haut parleurs on retrouve le code de
couleurs de orange même sur le côté là
pour le bouton convient à lui mais ça
c'est plutôt bien bouton voulu ici on
retrouve ici votre haut-parleurs de la
recharge en usb type ses tiroirs de
cartes sim qui est là à vous d'avoir le
haut parleur devant le micro qui
planquaient aussi ici mon avis de
l'autre côté vous n'avez absolument rien
et sur le dessus le micro pour réduction
bruit et on retrouve ici un triple
module photo est bien évidemment
regarder le petit powered by orange bien
bien gris fort enjeu bien fait pas mal
alignées comme ça on a ici le petit
branding alors sais pas si vous voyez
bien que ceux-ci de lemaitre comme ça on
voit ici marqué zte corporation c'est le
nom du fabricant du smartphone crypte le
module photo 48,20 +8 et à l'avant vous
avez une caméra dont 20 mégapixels
ensuite à l'intérieur on va se retrouver
l'art pour novembre on récupère ça
qu'est ce qu'on a ici laissez moi
regarder up de courir aux tiroirs des
cartes sim mais vague est alors dans
quelques-uns x 40 rebonds voit
effectivement qu'on à la caméra cela
nous indique à pouss place à on voit
qu'on a un capteur d'empreintes
digitales sweet crude plutôt pas mal de
la quick charge de 0 à 100 % en 2 heures
ou qui est pas mal mais peut faire mieux
on laisse venir tu as assez intéressant
46e méga pixels x 800 et qui vendent 28
mm 12 mégapixels f 2.4 équivalent de 16
mm donc ça c'est un grand-angle 8
mégapixels eve 2.5 4000 mètres c'est
votre télé objectif le petit flash led
ici auquel vont nous explique comment ça
marche on est vraiment pris par la
mosquée plutôt pas mal tiroirs de cartes
sim est ici la carte d'extension microsd
plutôt bien nos clients nous précise
bien intérieure aux c'est vraiment bien
parce que là on vous a dit vraiment on
nous indique l'un vous insérez votre
carte sim 2
vous allumez votre mobile vous entrez
votre code pin et là on a tous des infos
et un gros focus qui fait sur la
sécurité plutôt bien pour les personnes
qui effectivement très novices se
connaîtraient patron besoin
d'information s'est assez bien
démagnétisation enfants en bas âge
antenne ok on encore ensuite précautions
d'usagé garantie bien et on a une petite
coque transparente
c'est pas mal en termes d' usage si vous
voulez parce que alors effectivement
pour ceux qui sont habitués aux
smartphones vous dirigez pas besoin
qu'on prenne par la main et comme le
donne des informations comme ça mais
pour plein de personnes qui sont pas
forcément hyper hyper habitués et qui
ont besoin d'un peu plus d aide pour
installer leur smartphone ça peut avoir
un sens en tout cas c'est bien que ce
soit présent à l'intérieur de la boîte
ensuite la petite coque transparente bon
c'est parce qu'être plus folichon mais
ça marche et puis en tout cas vous allez
à venir et harrier donc on va pas de
critiquer qu'est-ce qu'on a ensuite ici
on va récupérer ce avec le blog de
charge de suppose c'est ça bloque de
charge rapide et on va bien le logo une
fois de plus du constructeur zte qui ici
quand suite ici on va récupérer le câble
d'alimentation avec la recharge en usb
c'est les écouteurs qui sont là parce
qu'une fois de plus c'est obligatoire et
vous le voyez vous avez des écouteurs
avec une prise jack
on a bien l'adaptateur ici prise jack
usb c'est donc vous prenez vos écouteurs
vous le branchez là dedans vous le
branchez là dedans je trouve ça pas très
pratique ça aurait été bien d'avoir
directement des écouteurs usb c'est ça
ne me ressemble en tout cas aller dans
le bon sens tout cas voir salle plus
l'accessoire
si vous perdez accessoires vos écouteurs
deviennent inutilisables bon ça c'est un
petit peu dommage
allumage entre le logo orange pour
android petit animation plutôt rigolote
commencer j'aime bien le design le
travail qui a été fait là dessus est ce
qui est assez drôle c'est qu'avec ce
fond d'écran qui très très bien pensé et
très bien vu de la part d'orange
effectivement vous avez le toujours le
petit carré logotype orange et pour le
coup ici votre caméra elle est bien bien
planqué si je me mets sur le plastron
vous le voyez bien alors vous voyez
c'est une belle petite encoche goutte
d'eau dont l'écran est assez bord à bord
bon laissez moi le temps de bien prendre
le smartphone en main de bien y habituer
de bien voir ce qui est bien les points
positifs les points négatifs de faire
plein de photos de vous dire ce qu'il en
est en termes de performances en termes
de photos en termes d'ergonomie en
termes de plein de choses pour moi ça va
durer quelques jours pour vous ça a duré
le temps d'un claquement de doigts
c'était il ya quelques jours quelques
semaines quelques bonnes semaines déjà
que j'ai tourné tout made
vidéo vous avez le temps du claquement
de doigts sur le nez va jet de hanche et
maintenant et leur neveu m l'heure est
venue de vous dire je me kill tous les
maux dont beaucoup s'en sert mieux
maintenant l'heure est venue de vous
dire ce que j'en pense comment est ce
que je le trouve ce smartphone alors il
ya des points qui sont vraiment cool et
des choses qui sont un peu moins bonne
et bonne nouvelle ça smartphones qui est
à gagner pour participer c'est facile
vous avez le lien en bas la description
vous pouvez y aller merci qui merci
orange merci monsieur comme ça vous
allez pouvoir vous amuser avec sans
aucun problème dans l'ensemble sauf que
c'est plutôt un bon smartphone côté
performances ça fonctionne c'est un
smartphone qui est assez rapide on a un
des derniers soc de qualcomm les 855
fait quand même franchement la faire
c'est une version avec 6 giga de ram 128
go de stockage extensible jusqu'à deux
terrains donc franchement en termes de
capacités de calcul en terme de stockage
là dessus on est tranquille et
absolument aucun problème
on a un score tout de 438 1833 sauviac
nos smartphones et puissant performance
nous le classent entre le samsung galaxy
note 10 et le mindaf les pros entre la
12e et la 13e position l'autonomie aussi
excellentes grosse batterie 4000
milliards erreurs on a de la coupe
charge de qualcomm c'est un smartphone
qui va assez bien que vous n'avez pas
regardé deux jours sans aucun problème
on est dans les standards actuels
c'est un produisait de zte a sorti ce
produit l'axone 10 pro 5 g il a été
présenté le 25 février 2019 pour être
très précis
c'est donc un smartphone du début
d'année et non pas de la fin d'année
2010 notent donc il n'ya pas les
dernières technologies
il ya beaucoup de projets qui sont
sortis entre temps mais néanmoins ce
smartphone la reste quand même plutôt
pas mal en rien un truc que je vais un
peu moins aimé c'est la partie des
verrouillages le capteur d'empreintes
digitales fonctionne pas toujours et
quand il fonctionne
il est quand même relativement lent la
voyez là deux essais ça ne marche pas il
faut vraiment bien le positionner c'est
un peu la galère ça pour moi c'est un
truc un petit peu négatif alors à prier
notre moyen pour les dérouillée vous
avez la reconnaissance faciale l'ouest
c'est un androïde 9 paille la surcouche
est pas complètement dingue c'est parce
que je vais préférer par rapport à tout
ce qu'on peut retrouver sur le marché on
s'adresse vraiment aux clients de orange
là dessus au lait sur un smartphone
s'enfonçant orange même si c'est un
smartphone est il complètement adapté à
l'univers d'orange imaginons que si vous
êtes client orange ou si vous remontez
le devenir vous aurez pas le faire
tomber
vous aurez pas de souci que ce
partenaire dites moi si vous êtes client
chez orange et si un produit comme celui
là pourrait potentiellement vous
intéresser à côté de ça on a c'était
quand même très grande série de 47
pouces à sa marche pour division
ashton va on a un écran qu'occupe 92
profond de la face avant je trouve bien
moi de ce point de vue là je suis
vraiment tranquille sonne à molette
résolution de 1340 par 1080 pixels ça
marche fort de visionner ce de contenus
séries films tout ce que vous voulez ça
fonctionne ça fait le job
j'avais des haut-parleurs stéréo un
auteur qui est planqué là et l'autre
alors qu'ils utilisaient ces leurres
l'opa alors là un son qui est grave
parce que pas mal à un spectre qui est
assez intéressant celui là par contre a
contrario l'index couche tard on entend
est vraiment pas de puissance
le son est très médium il ya
déséquilibre entre celui là est celui là
ça fait une petite piqûre de rappel ça
rapporte un petit feu de son pourquoi
pas à noter qu'il ya plusieurs versions
de ce smartphone alors la version vous
allez acheter le nevada jet c'est un
smartphone 5 g mais ce produit là chez
zte
il ya deux versions il ya une version 4g
6 +128 et il est une version 5 g 6
pouces 128 et 8 plus 256 alors la
différence se fait au niveau du modem là
vous avez le modem de qualcomm c'est sa
dragonne x50 modène 5j qui vous permet
effectivement de vous connecter à la
saint jean côté photo qu'est ce que ça
dit eh bien il ya du bon et du pas bon
pas bon pour les photos emploi jeu dont
vous avez beaucoup de lumière ça
fonctionnera et vous montrer en quelques
instants par contre pour le reste c'est
assez moyen
malgré que je sois projet déjà si vous
n'avez pas stabilisation vous mettre ça
pour venir illustrer le propos
là vous avez aucune stabilisation donc
avec moi je pars si vous vous en
souvenez mais ça pardonne pas regarder
la voyez il ya aucune stamm optique
ça bouge au kunst abeilles chronique et
lorsque je vais monter sur le x 3 c'est
pareil ça bouge
et lorsque je passe sur l'ultra grand
angle c'est pareil ça bouge les photos
de nuit c'est pareil si vous n'êtes pas
stabilisée c'est la galère ça me
reprocher parce que ça vient peut
bloquer l'expérience vous avez besoin
d'une stabilisation
on n'est pas toujours dans les
conditions extraordinaires avec un
trépied on a souvent france marc faune à
la main que l'on prend bhl ou pas quand
ils s'en sont jamais parfaites et là
avec ce smartphone pour moi c'est un des
points bloquants et c'est embêtant alors
il ya pas mal de modes un mode portrait
automatique flou nuit bon ça on connaît
ça d'un point de vue logiciel ça
fonctionne le grand temps que vous avez
un mode en plus ici alors vous pouvez
venir la voir sur le mode automatique
avec la petite molette
bon pourquoi pas par mail illustré mais
pas mal de petites fonctionnalités ça
peut être intéressant il ya un autre
point j'aime pas trop c'est la
différence que vous allez avoir au
niveau de la colorimétrie entre les
différents capteurs parce que les gars
vous raconte pas ce que c'est qu'un en
coloriser la suisse en grand-angle je
vais avoir quelque chose d'un peu plus
coloré et plus je change d'angle up et
moi j'ai deux couleurs là la différence
vous voyez un peu sur le jaune entre la
somme qu'on entend dans les plus
éclatants les plus saturés
on est un petit peu moins saturé il est
qu'on passe sur le téléobjectif on perd
encore en saturation
alors ici on est très éclairé donc ça
ravive un peu les couleurs mais lorsque
vous le faites à l'extérieur croyez moi
que ça se joue et qu'on voit quand même
vraiment la différence et ça c'est pas
terrible
nous avions trois objectifs en arrière
le grand temps vous avez enfin vous
switchez et ensuite du foin os x 2 c'est
du zoom numérique et pour avoir le
téléobjectif
on passe directement en x 3 et là on le
voit ensuite au volant d'un petit cran
d'un point de vue logiciel et après on a
un zoom complètement numérique là dessus
il a la qualité elle est pas
complètement rien bon ça c'est pas
anormal s'est pas non plus fait pour ça
là par exemple une photo qui étaient
prises en extérieur bondé voulait
beaucoup de lumière ça fonctionne c'est
l'objectif principal on arrive ensuite
avec le zoom zoom est ici en x 3 la
qualité est pas complètement dingue vous
regarder derrière au niveau des arbres
eh bien on a un côté qui est un peu plus
floue bon ça fait à peu près le taf là
dès qu'on arrive sur une fois main voyez
tout c'est pas terrible
d'autant plus qu'on a aucune
stabilisation là dessus donc bourg le
résultat est pas ou l'ultra grand
parleur fonctionne dès lors vous avez de
la lumière ou mais voyez dès qu'on
arrive toute oppression de faible
luminosité bah c'est pas terrible les
couleurs au niveau de la statue la place
de la république c'est pas beau du tout
il ya un espèce de lissage un truc qui
est vraiment pas très très beau deuxième
photo prise de la même manière voyez le
résultat est pas terrible on continue il
n'y a pas de stade ça bouge c'est
horrible deuxième tentative c'est pas
terrible non plus on continue encore
voyez salissent le bonhomme devant ça
ressemble presque à une esquive
artistique un peu bizarre et un peu
loupé de ce point de vue là la photo nue
est vraiment vraiment pas terrible on
continue la voyez avec des mouvements
devant ça vous fera espèce de folie sage
mouvement dégoûtant c'est pas beau la
photo nuit franchement c'est pas
terrible il faut vraiment le poser sur
un pied qui aucun mouvement qu'on les
résultats qu'elles soient sensiblement
un tout petit peu correct dès qu'on
arrive par contre toi jours place de la
république
regardez comme c'est joli là ça va ça
fonctionne plutôt pas mal on vient où
mac os x 3 ça fonctionne à peu près
l'ultra grand va on voit quelle
différence de couleur au niveau de la
statue au niveau de l' ultra grand-angle
et des conneries d'être le foie rein bon
voilà c'est pas terrible terrible la
gestion des lumières à contre jour c'est
pas où mais bon c'est pas anormal non
plus on vient se rapprocher avec les
autres voies 2
on récupère du oui le x 20 on a beaucoup
de bruit c'est très imprécis et pas
terrible l'ultra grand temps et beaucoup
de lumière ça fait le taf comme sept ans
marthe phone gris florange même s'il est
fabriqué par zte s'adresse aux clients
de orange aux clients actuels et aux
clients à venir je trouve que ça
smartphones qui est plutôt intéressant
il a quelques défauts le capteur
d'empreinte digitale est pas
complètement ouf
il a une goutte d'eau sur deux
smartphones haut de gamme c'est parce
que je préfère et fin 2019 début 2020
mais il reste dans les standards actuels
donc ça je veux pas lui reprocher je
trouve suffisamment performant je trouve
suffisamment ans durant maintenant je
trouve un peu cher vu ce qu'on peut
trouver à la concurrence on est sur un
smartphone qui annonce est nu chez
orange à 899 euros 90 centimes zte
aujourd'hui en france c'est pas très
connu il ya très peu de personnes qui
vont se dire ok je vais aller acheter un
smartphone zte
je suis pas non plus sûr qu'on ait pu
dire tiens je vais acheter un smartphone
signé orange a quasiment 900 euros a
quasiment neuf cents euros je vais aller
acheter un smartphone de apple un
smartphone de samsung un smartphone de
huawei un smartphone qui me rassure un
smartphone dont je connais la marque je
suis pas sûr que la marque orange soit
suffisamment forte pour qu'on ait envie
de poser 900 euros dessus je suis pas
sûr que c'était suffisamment fort en
france qu'on a envie de poser 900 euros
dessus c'est un smartphone qui peut
fonctionner en tout cas avec le système
de forfaits et de crédit vous avez payé
votre smartphone un peu moins cher à
l'achat et vous allez prendre un
engagement sur 24 mois 24 12 mois à mon
avis là dessus ça peut fonctionner avec
une vraie clientèle orange qui est dans
l'écosystème qui est habitué angers qui
rassurait par orange mais sur un client
lambda qui va poser 900 euros sur un
smartphone eu personnellement j'y crois
pas à côté de ça je trouve pas mal
le smartphone est plutôt bien mais une
fois de plus si on va l'acheter nu que
je trouve que par rapport à la
concurrence
on y part qui préférait à ce moment là
les sur impétrantes pro que j'ai trouvé
beaucoup moins cher qui sera beaucoup
mieux que ce produit là qui entame de
photos d'hier est quand même beaucoup
plus loin
comment vous trouvez vous en tout cas ce
smartphone neva jet de oro est ce que
vous trouvez sexy intéressant oui non
tout ça quoique monde marqué ça on va en
commentaire à chaud vous êtes chez
l'opérateur
et est ce que vous pourriez si vous
n'êtes pas chez orange est ce que vous
pourriez switcher chez orange pour le
névé jet ou alors est ce que pour vous
ça n'a strictement aucun intérêt marqué
moi ça en barque au matin va nous on se
retrouve dès demain on continue à parler
de textes vous embrasse a deux matches à
eau